gigi hadid steps out in Italy for Milan  Fashion Week and things turned scary  check out Gigi ditching her pants for  Fashion Week  she showed off her supermodel legs in a  nude bodysuit paired with a metallic  coat later ripping the runway for the  Max Mara show but on Thursday Gigi was  attacked by a man while exiting the show  with her sister Bella Hadid photos show  him grabbing her from behind and lifting  her in the air  the model made headlines for fighting  back and a fan quickly took to social  media to defend her I saw that on  Twitter Gigi thanked the user tweeting I  am a human being and had every right to  defend myself how dare that idiot think  he has the right to manhandle a complete  stranger he ran quick though and  according to TMZ the man is the  notorious Vitaly Sudoku who has made his  way on too many red carpets even once  hugging Bradley Cooper